JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Hello.
Ooh, nice and loud, thank you.
Hi, I'm Jessica Dene Earley-Cha,
and I'm a Developer Advocate
for Actions on Google.
Welcome.
I'm really excited that
you're all here, especially
because it's the
end of a long day.
So thank you for trucking
along and keeping it going.
So hopefully, I
have enough energy
if you don't to feed off on.
And then, what's nice is after
this, we go to happy hour,
so we'll have a good time there.
Yeah.
Oh, well, thank you.
So just in case, just
to make sure everyone
knows they're in
the right spot, this
is the Intro to Building
Serverless Apps for Google Home
and Google Assistant.
So if you are not interested
in this, don't worry,
you could sneak out.
That's A-OK by me.
Before we really start
and dive into how
to build, let's talk about
a little bit of the user
perspective and let's just
ground ourselves there first.
I really want to
start off with there's
a shift that's going
on right now in regard
to how users are
interacting with technology,
and this happens
every couple of years.
For the sake of
this talk, we just
said, every 10 years or
so there's a major shift.
One of the last
major shifts have
been when we went mobile first.
And I remember being in college
and having my flip phone
and not understanding
why would I want
to have internet on my phone.
That just seemed really
weird and strange.
Now in 2018, it's like,
oh my gosh, of course,
I live with my phone.
My phone takes me everywhere.
My phone organizes my life.
And so that shift, I
definitely lived through
and I recognize that.
And so right now, we're
in a different shift
when it comes to artificial
intelligence and assistance.
And so the way users are
interacting with technology
is definitely different, and
this comes Google Assistant.
Google Assistant
is where we want
to be able to give users a
way to interact with Google
where they can be more
productive, get things done,
and to enjoy life a lot more.
So you can say things like,
OK Google, turn on some music.
I'm going to try to refrain
from saying that phrase
because I don't want to
trigger anyone's phone.
So you could say that
phrase and get things done,
turn on the lights,
do this, do that,
be able to make it
easier for our users.
So Google Assistant, right now
we have over a million actions
on the platform.
We're also on over
500 million devices.
And so this number is
really, really amazing,
because Google Assistant
is kind of everywhere now.
We're not just on phones,
but we're on laptops,
we're on [? Korean ?]
cars, we're on watches.
And the way we can
interact with users
is everywhere, because
we want to be supportive.
Also, we're in lots of different
languages and locales as well.
So let's break this apart in
regards to what, as developers,
can we do with Google Assistant.
So there's the actual
physical device, which there's
over 500 million devices.
And so that is your Google
Homes, your Google Minis.
This is the machine.
This is the hardware.
Next, there is Google Assistant.
This is Google's product where
it's supportive, it's helpful,
it's fantastic.
Then there's Actions on Google.
And that's a platform that
developers could really
shine and be able to build
really interesting things.
So Actions on Google
is just our platform.
Similar to other
platforms, like Android,
we have developers
who build what
we call "actions"
on the platform
to give users a better and
more rich experience as well.
So for the sake
of this talk, I'm
going to pretend I
have a bike shop.
So I own a business, where
it's a friendly local business.
And I have always wanted
to be a very healthy person
in this alternate universe.
I believe there's a Jessica
there that is really active
and she rides bikes.
Unfortunately, that's not me.
So I can definitely
invite you to come
into my little
world I've created
where I own a bike shop, and
this is kind of my world.
This is an alternate
life I have.
And so in my bike
shop, I want to be
able to provide my users some
really great interactions
and just to be there for
them when they need me most.
And so there's different
moments and times
where users might
want to interact
with my actual business.
And so I was thinking about,
what kind of interactions
would someone want
to use if they're
thinking about a bike shop?
And so the first thing I
thought of was the hours.
That's pretty common.
I want to be able to give
the ability to my users
to ask, what are your hours?
But I want to go one step
further where it's not just
so much what your hours are,
but if someone's on their bike
and it's broken, they want to
know, can I come in right now?
That's really the question.
And so I want to provide
that functionality as well,
where they can ask
me, are you open now?
And I can actually find
out-- "hey, where are you?
Can we figure this
out?"-- be able to
give you that attraction,
give you that response.
And then I also thought,
I have a point of sales,
and in there, I actually use a
Firebase to store all my data.
And so I have this
ability to be able to know
what I have in
stock, because I want
to be able to give my users
that type of response.
Because I know I hate
when I go to the store
and they don't have the
product I'm looking for.
That's really
infuriating for me.
So I want to be able to
give my users the ability
to be able to
figure out, do they
want to come in and do I have
the things that they want?
So we're going to
build that today.
This is a very
small project just
to illustrate the
things they could do,
and we're going to
build this from scratch.
So high level, this is kind
of what we're working with.
On the left-hand side, the
user could say something
like, OK Google, talk
to the Bike Shop Demo.
The device hears
it, and what it does
is it sends the audio
to Google Assistant.
Google Assistant
will parse it out.
We'll use a natural
language processor.
We use our Knowledge Graph,
our machine learning ranking,
all the jazz to figure out
which action is the best
action that the user wants.
This is really, really similar--
so when you go to the
physical Google.com
and you put something
into the search bar,
it's really similar to
that type of technology.
So Google Assistant
does that, figures out,
"OK, there is a Bike
Shop Demo that exists.
Let me trigger that."
And Google Assistant will
tell the user, sure, here's
the Bike Shop Demo.
And then now, my action
that I'm building now
will be able to greet my user.
My Action will say something
to the effect of "hello,
welcome to The Bike Shop.
How can I help you?"
After that, the user will
be able to respond back
asking for what the hours are.
That, again, goes
to Google Assistant,
and it should give a response of
"I'm open from 9:00 AM to 5:00
PM Monday through Friday."
So that's the goal.
That's kind of where
we're going and these are
the players we're working with.
So first things
first, let's actually
start a project on
Actions on Google.
There we go.
And the power of
technology, I'm actually
going to be playing a video.
That way we don't
mess anything up
and I don't have to
worry about my typing.
So I'm at the Actions
on Google console.
I've just created an Action.
It drops me into this
really nice platform,
or this console, where it has
on the left-hand side Setup,
Build, Test and
deploy, and Measure.
And so this helps guide
us through our development
of our Action.
We're going to skip the
setup part because I
want to go straight
to being able to code
and making sure that
we finish this in time.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go to Build
and I'm going to
go to Action, so
I can actually build the
functionality I want.
And so here is where I have
a question that I'm not
really sure how
I want to handle,
and we have a couple of options.
When it comes to
user's requests,
I know for me,
sometimes when I'm
speaking I don't speak
the best grammar--
like that sentence--
but generally,
people can understand me.
And I know there's
going to be users that
are similar to me who
they might say things
a little differently,
or a little wonky,
but I want to be able to
process their information
and give them the correct
feedback or correct responses
that they want.
So I was thinking
about a scenario
that I had drawn up in my head.
And I could definitely see
myself saying something
like this.
"I got this bike last year.
On Friday, I got a flat.
Can I come in right now?"
And of course, for us as
humans, we could parse that out
and figure out OK, what
the person is really asking
is if they can
come in right now.
But you could imagine
trying to write
a regular expression trying to
pull out the dates and times
and the sense of "Friday,"
and "last year," and "now,"
and trying to figure that out.
[INAUDIBLE] could
be a little messy.
And I don't necessarily want
to have to deal with all that.
I want to be able to
have something that's
a little easier of a tool.
And that's when
Dialogflow comes in.
Dialogflow is an intent matching
and entity extraction tool
that we could use.
It connects really nicely
with Actions on Google.
And what is going to
happen is Dialogflow
is going to do a lot of
the heavy lifting for us.
It's going to grab the raw
text that the user says, tries
to figure out the intent
with the intent matching,
and pulls out any
of the entities
that we've predefined that are
important that we would like
to extract from the phrases.
So with Dialogflow,
this is their console,
just to give you a sneak peek.
We're going to be
using this tool
with our Actions on Google.
So let's update our
diagram now, now
that things have
changed a little.
So we've added Dialogflow
to our diagram.
And now when Actions
on Google gets--
when it first starts,
it gets triggered,
it's going to trigger Dialogflow
and the welcome intent.
And so now Dialogflow is going
to be handling that response
of the greeting that we have.
Likewise, also, every time
that the user speaks to us,
Google Assistant will
do the whole audio
to text transformation and then
sends the text to Dialogflow.
And Dialogflow will handle the
natural language processing
in regards to that response.
Cool.
So now we have that.
So let's actually
build this out.
So let's start on
Actions on Google,
let's connect all
these together.
So from here, from the console,
we're going to add an action,
build a custom action.
And this drops us
right into Dialogflow.
We're going to
create a new agent.
So that's a new
agent for Dialogflow.
It will be connected.
And we're going
to go to Intents.
Dialogflow, by default,
gives us two intents.
First one is Welcome.
So let's modify Welcome.
As you could see, it already has
a sense of events and training
phrases.
And training phrases
is what Dialogflow
will use with its machine
learning to figure out
the intents components.
And so, by default,
Dialogflow gives us
a lot of great examples
for training phrases,
different ways of saying "hello"
and starting the conversation.
So we'll have all those.
Those are great.
And now here with my responses,
I want to make some edits
and make it more customized.
And so I delete one.
So I want three.
And this gives us the option of
having three different options
that our user could hear.
So Dialogflow, whenever
it gets triggered,
will just do a random
from these three options.
So I'm just going to edit
this text so they can have
the welcome to The Bike Shop.
After that, we're
going to hit Save.
On the bottom
right-hand corner, you
see that the intent gets saved
and that the agent's training
actually starts.
And so it's in real
time building out
the machine learning model.
Builds that out.
And on the top right-hand
corner, I could type in "hi"
and we get the
response back already.
If you guys can't see, up here,
that's where I typed in "hi."
The user was able to get that.
And then this is our
response that we get back.
So in Dialogflow, we
can test this out.
But let's test this out
on the actual console
for Actions on Google.
So we go to Integrations,
Integration Settings,
and we're going
to click on Test.
We'll do some Continue.
It's going to ask to make
sure everything's good.
It's connecting everything,
which is awesome.
And now we're dropped
into the simulator.
This is where, in
Actions on Google,
you could test out your
actions before you deploy
and you take it out.
And so in here, right
in the middle part,
right here is the simulator.
On the right-hand side is
different options where
it shows the display, what
the users will be seeing,
as well as the requests and
response, and any bugs as well,
or errors, that shows up.
And you could see the logs, too.
So really great tool.
So we're going to do Talk
to my test app in here.
Fantastic.
So our Actions on Google
gave us back the "Good day.
Welcome to The Bike Shop.
What can I do for you today?"
Which worked out wonderfully,
so that worked out.
So now let's build
out this next intent.
And let me just elaborate
more on what intents are.
Intents are the functionality
we want to give to our users.
This is an option that a
user can say something,
so then this action can happen,
this part of my bigger action
can be invoked.
And so we're going to build out
the currently open possibility.
So I'm going to go
back to my video.
So we're going to go back into
Dialogflow, to that console,
bring out of here.
Go back to Intents.
And we're going to
create a new intent.
So in here, we're going
to name our intents--
oh, I'm sorry, we're actually
going to build our hours.
Apologies.
I got excited.
I'm going to go
back to my slides.
We're going to
build this guy out.
So sorry.
I'm really excited about
this, as you could tell.
This is really, really awesome.
So we're going to build our
hours, still in the same space.
Here, we're actually going to be
adding in our training phrases.
So again, this is
what Dialogflow
is going to be using to be
able to figure out the intent
matching.
And so with this
verbiage that we have,
we want to have as many
examples of training phrases
that users could possibly say.
This is a really great
time to get your UX testing
folks to get involved.
And if you have designers,
when it comes to conversation,
get them involved too.
If you don't, great thing to do
is just ask people around you,
how would you say this?
And be able to track that.
So in here, we tracked
it, and now we're
going to add a response.
So anytime someone asks this
or says these type of phrases,
our Action's going to
respond back with "we're open
Monday through Friday--
or "we're open from 9:00 to
5:00, Monday through Friday."
And we're going to hit Save.
Fantastic, the
training has already
happened on the bottom
right-hand corner.
Great.
Let's go back to our Actions on
Google console and let's test
this out.
So we're going to
reset the simulator.
Let's start this by doing
Talk to my test app.
Cool, that worked.
Great.
And now let's type in
"what are your hours?"
Or "when are you open?"
Awesome.
It worked.
So it gave us "we're
open from 9:00 to 5:00,"
but notice I put
"when are you open?"
And I actually didn't have
that in my training phrases.
So again, Dialogflow
was able to figure out
that this phrase matched the
closest with the hours intent
that we had.
Super easy.
So now we're going to go with
the currentlyOpen intent,
and so this gives us
the option for the users
to be able to ask us,
are you open right now?
So let's build this
out, and this one
is going to be a little
different from the hours one.
But we're going to go
from the beginning.
We create a new intent.
We're going to name it.
I'm going to use camel
case because in my backend
I'll be using
Javascript, so I want
to be able to keep
this consistent.
We're going to add some
training phrases as well.
So these have to do with
"can I come in now?"
"Are you open now?"
"Are you currently open?"
Mind you, I'm only using a small
example because of the demo,
but the more phrases that you
put in, the better Dialogflow
is going to perform for you.
Cool.
We're going to go
down to Responses.
And here, I don't want to
give a default response.
This is not going
to be truthful.
I can't just put, "you're
open now," or "yes, we are"
without knowing
where the user is
and be able to figure out
what time is it of the day.
So here, I actually
deleted the response.
And I'm going to go
down to Fulfillment,
and I'm going to
enable the webhook.
That way, when this
intent gets called,
it's going to go
to my fulfillment.
Going to hit Save and test it.
Normally, I would test it, but
my fulfillment is my backend,
and we haven't
built that out yet.
So we have this
possibility, but we
haven't connected all the way.
So I'm going to
put a pin in that
and we're going to keep going.
And we're going to build out
the intent of tire stock.
This is the idea that
people could ask me,
"do you have this type of tire?"
That way, if they're
riding their bike
and they pull out their phone,
they're talking to my Action
because their bike just broke,
they could ask me in real time,
"do you have something?"
And I want to give that
functionality to them.
So let's build that part out.
Fantastic.
Similarly, I'm going
to create a new intent.
I'm going to call
this tiresStocked.
And I want to give it
some training phrases.
So I put in "my mountain
bike," but I kind of
feel like I'm missing
something here.
I kind of want to be able
to know what type of tire
I'm using--
or what tire my
user wants to get.
So if you double
click in Entities
that exist in Dialogflow.
So Dialogflow
understands this idea
of time, measurements,
common names as well.
And so there's nothing
like a tire type
when it comes to
entities with Dialogflow.
That's a special niche
thing that only my company
or my business does.
So what am I going to do instead
is I want to make my own.
So let's cancel this intent
and let's go to Entities.
In here, I could build out
my own custom entities.
So this entity I'm
going to call tireType.
This is the idea of a tire type.
And in here, I'm going
to be able to predefine--
there's this idea of a mountain
tire, which you could also
use the actual measurements
of 27.5 times 2.0,
or cross country.
And so what's going
to happen here
is all these synonyms that
I'm providing to Dialogflow,
if a user uses that, it knows,
oh, the user means mountain.
And so it's going to
reduce back to "mountain,"
and in my backend,
I'm only having
to handle this idea of mountain.
Similarly with road terrain,
if someone says racing or uses
the measurement of
700 times 23, it's
going to just reduce
down to road terrain.
And so again, my
backend, I only have
to worry about this one
variable or this one
possible value for the tire
type entity that we're creating.
So I've made all those.
Fantastic.
I'm going to go
back to my intents,
and let's build this out again.
So again, tiresStocked.
And now here with
the training phrases,
I'm going to type in something
to the effect of "my mountain
bike."
For some reason, "mountain" is
a really challenging word for me
to spell.
I know, right?
You have no idea how many
times I recorded this.
This is why I didn't want
to have to live-type it.
So "my mountain bike got a flat.
Do you have tires?"
And here, I could click on that.
And now I could identify
it as a tire type.
So now Dialogflow
knows, oh, this
is a thing I need to
keep track of and give
to the developer on the backend.
And now when I did the
BMX one, it automatically
did that for me.
So now Dialogflow has learned
that this is information
that I really want to
keep and keep track of.
Mind you, there are times where
numbers is a system in entity,
and so I just have to help
Dialogflow a little bit
by going, nope, this whole
thing is a tire type.
So we just give it
super easy, super nice.
I heard someone say, sweet.
That's awesome.
Dialogflow is amazing.
So with this, I'm going to
say that this is required.
I need this for my
intent to be triggered.
And if someone just
says, do you have tires?
I could ask them automatically,
what type of bike?
That way, I'm not having to
handle that back and forth,
but Dialogflow will for me.
Cool.
Made that.
Again, I don't want to
do an automatic response.
I want to be able to figure
this out dynamically.
So I'm going to enable my
fulfillment and hit Save.
Cool.
Fantastic.
So we have these three intents
built out that we customized.
And now, next
thing we want to do
is we actually want
to build the webhook.
We want to build it where after
Dialogflow has been triggered,
it goes and we can
handle this data.
Actions on Google, we
have a client library
written in Node.js.
And this is just an example
of what the hours intent would
look like if we didn't
automatically program that in,
where it was automatically
responded by Dialogflow.
This is what it would look like.
What I really enjoy about
this is that you just
make an instance of
Dialogflow, set it to app,
and now you could
just do app.intent,
passing in the title or
the name of your intent
in Dialogflow, which
for this example
would be "hours," passes
in the conversation object.
And then in my
function itself, I
do conv.ask and then
pass in a string.
Super, super simple.
This is kind of the basic
thing that you can do.
There's a lot more really fun
things that you do in addition.
We'll get to that later.
So let's build this out.
Let's build out the
currentlyOpen intent.
Cool.
I forgot to mention.
I'm going to go back here.
You never want to start
things from scratch.
So on our GitHub repo, we
do have a Dialogflow webhook
template for Node.js.
That will have some
boilerplate code.
And that's what we're going
to be starting off with.
So this is the code that we're
going to be starting off with.
It has, by default,
which is really great,
the Welcome intent that
Dialogflow gives us.
So here we're going to
just edit that to be
written for our currentlyOpen.
So here, a big note,
if it's not spelled
the same as camel case--
or capitalization
sensitive-- case sensitive--
your intent name has to
match with this string.
So what we're doing is
we're going to check
to see if it's currently open.
And then we're going
to pass in the string
that, yeah, we're currently
open now, we close at 5:00
PM, with the conv.ask.
And then if it's not currently
open, we'll let our user know.
So "we're currently not--
well, "we're currently closed,
but we open every weekday."
That way, depending on
whatever time it is,
my user will be able to get
the appropriate response.
So I also have to build out the
actual function of currently
open.
This tracks to make sure that
the time stamp or the date time
is correct.
I'm also making a
lot of assumptions
that this person is in
California, because I only
have one shop.
I'm not international yet.
But there are ways to be
able to get information
from the user of what location
they're at, a rough location.
So you could ask for
that permission as well.
That way, you could
have that and then
be able to track to
see what of your stores
is the closest one to
the user's location.
Cool.
So we built that out.
This is the code.
You guys saw me write it, so
let's move on to the next one.
So let's connect this.
Let's try this out.
We've written our intent.
Now we've written the
fulfillment for that intent.
Let's deploy this.
Seeing the way the
client library is built,
serverless sounds like
a really great option.
I don't need a lot
of that overhead.
And so something that
we really enjoy is,
again, we don't need all that
infrastructure because we only
are using that app.intent.
And then also,
what's really great
is that we're not paying
for when we're not using it.
So let's say if I build
the next great application
and it goes off,
Google Assistant
is on over 500 million devices.
My Action will be able
to scale really easily
with that as well.
So we choose to use serverless.
And we're going to
be using Google Cloud
Functions, because when
Dialogflow receives
the raw text, parses it
out, figures out the intent,
it will trigger to our
Google Cloud function, which
will trigger our actual
backend response as well.
And again, what's really
nice, it's in Node.js,
so this all fits
really great together.
Let's update our image.
So from Dialogflow,
when it comes
after the Welcome intent--
because the Welcome intent
will be automatic at this point.
So when it's on the
"what are your hours?"
Dialogflow will do the parsing,
pull out any entities it needs,
and it's going to trigger
my Cloud functions.
Cool.
So let's build that out.
We're going to go to
here, to the Firebase's
is getting started.
And we'll grab all the
tools that we need.
So we'll NPM all of
the Firebase tools.
It's a great time to
take a water break.
Download everything,
all the magic.
I'm always worried that
it's going to take too long,
but it didn't, so it's great.
Cool, we did that.
We're going to scroll
down a little bit.
What I need to do is
make sure I'm logged in.
I already know I've
already logged in.
I know it will do the
Firebase init functions,
run that command.
What that's going
to be doing is it's
going to build everything
out and it's going
to ask me which project to use.
I'm going to use
my Bike Shop Demo.
I'm letting it know that
I'm using JavaScript.
Do I want my cell
to be enforced?
Yes.
Do I want everything
to be overwritten?
Yes, please.
And install all the
dependencies I need.
So that's going to take a
couple of seconds, not too long.
Cool.
It's doing the magic.
Fantastic.
Now that's all
completed in there.
Now, the next thing to
do is just to deploy.
Find the command, so Firebase
deploy --only functions.
We have to cd into our
function's directory,
go in there.
That's a good note.
Make sure you do that.
If you don't, it won't work.
So you cd into
functions, directory,
then you run the command,
does all the jazz.
And it works.
And then from here, it's
going to give you a URL.
From that URL,
you're going to be
able to access the
actual URL that's
going to be live to
get to your backend.
So in Firebase, you're
going to grab that
URL from the Functions option.
That was a little fast,
so let's do this again.
Cool.
Grab that URL.
You're going to go Dialogflow.
And in Dialogflow, we're going
to go down to Fulfillment.
And in Fulfillment, we're
going to enable the webhook.
Enable that.
That's going to give us a spot
where we can put in our URL.
So if you decide
not to use Firebase,
you just want to use
something else, that's
where you would be adding
your own webhook URL.
And then in here, we're going
to scroll down, hit Save,
and this will connect
everything together.
Cool.
So now we're going to go
to our Actions on Google.
Let's talk to my test app.
Fantastic.
The default welcome
is going to happen,
gives us a little customized
with the greeting.
We're going to ask if we're
currently open, and we are.
We're currently open.
It is before 5:00.
So fantastic.
That worked.
So now I want to connect
this to my database.
I want to be able
to have it where
I could do the intent to make
sure I have all my stock.
I currently already
have everything
stored in my Cloud Firestore.
For those who are not familiar
with it, it's a NoSQL database,
and it's synchronous
and conflict resolution
in real time, which is
nice, because I'm going
to be-- things might happen.
People might be coming in,
stocking up, things get bought.
I want to be able to have
this where it's in real time.
So in order to connect
Firestore to our Action,
we just need to add
in these four lines,
pulling the Firebase's admin,
also the Firebase's functions,
and then also initializing
it and creating our database.
Cool, and now let's build
out our tire stock intent.
So I just want to
show you my database.
This is what it looks like.
This might be a max
bikes that I have
and everything that's in stock,
so you could see what I have.
I'm not in stock
with everything.
And I have quantities as well.
So that's how my
database looks like.
So in here, let's add in
those four lines of code
that we needed.
Fantastic.
And now let's start
building out that intent.
And so what's happening here is
we have our tire stock intent.
We're going to be
grabbing the parameters.
And so this one's
a little different.
We're on line 37.
We're passing in the
conversation object and params.
And so this is an
additional argument
that we get that we could gap
the parameters and the entities
that Dialogflow gives us.
And so on line 38, you
see params.tireTypes.
We make that into
our own variable.
So now we could grab what
Dialogflow is giving us
in regards to the tire type.
So it's only giving us four
options, which is great.
Then we're going to be
calling for our database,
passing in that tire type.
And making sure to
see, hey, do I even
have this tire type in stock?
Is it something I even
have documentation on?
If I don't, we could tell them,
sorry, we do not carry this.
And if we do and it's in stock,
we tell them, yes, we have it.
And if it's not in
stock, we say, sorry,
we're currently out of stock.
And then, of course,
you want to make sure
if there's any errors,
we capture that,
so that way we could
log our own errors
if something weird happens.
So let's try this out.
We already deployed it.
And then we're going
to talk to our action.
Cool, it gives us a
different greeting.
And now we're going to ask, do
you have BMX tires in stock?
Cool, we have it
and it's in stock.
Let's test out the
other ones just in case,
because I don't have
everything in stock.
"Do you carry cyclocross tires?"
That's how much of a bike
person I am, "cyclocross."
Well, sorry, we're
currently out of stock,
so we don't have that.
And then my favorite one,
"can I get mountain tires?"
"We have it and it's in stock."
Cool.
So there is the code that we
wrote out for that intent.
And so now let's update
our graph just to make sure
that we're all on the same page.
So now that we have our
Cloud Functions, and now
that from Cloud Function,
we could trigger and get
information from our
Firestore database.
And so this is
our updated image.
And then here you go.
After that, this is
my actual Action.
What we would want to
do before we deploy--
I want to show everything
to completion--
is you're going to want
to go back up to Setup.
And in Invocation,
you're going to want
to add in the invocation name.
The invocation name
is the actual name
that we're going to be
giving Google that it's going
to use that users can trigger.
And so for this
one, I'm most likely
going to want to use "Jessica's
bike shop" or "my bike shop
demo," because I really don't
want people to accidentally
trigger it.
You'd be putting that
information in there as well,
as well as picking out
to see what type of voice
you would like.
And then once you submit all of
that, we've already tested it,
we can go to Deploy.
And in here, you want
to add a description,
because we do have a directory.
So you add in your description,
your images, any sample
invocations, the
details of your company.
Another thing is you're going to
need a privacy policy as well.
So you input all of
this great information,
as well as the rest
of location targeting,
so what countries you want
to target, your service
capabilities.
So there's times where you might
build an Action that is not
its aim or can only
be used with images
or like a visual
interface as well,
and so you want be
able to note that.
That way, it's not triggerable
on things that does not
have any visual elements.
So something like a Google Home.
And so you'd be able to put
that information there too.
After that, we're going
to want to release it.
And so we've introduced at
Google I/O alpha and beta
releases as well.
So with alpha, you
could whitelist
about 20 emails in an account.
So that way, you could test
this out, making sure it works.
With the beta, you
could submit, but you
need to have your
privacy policy with this.
And it goes through
approval process.
With alpha, you do not
have to get approved,
because it's only for 20.
And with beta, you could
have it for 200 people.
And then you could do the
regular for production as well.
And so we would do that.
And that is my bike shop.
So high level, this is what
we did from end to end.
The conversation
goes up and around.
So from the user, potentially
all the way to our database,
and then all the way back.
So just another image
for those folks.
Taking a moment because
there's photos happening.
Just let people know.
Cool.
So one of the big
questions I get
is, oh, great, Jessica,
that's awesome.
You built a thing and
it's really nifty,
but how do people know
about these things?
How do we tell our customers?
Because that's
really what we want.
So a couple of ways,
just to let people know.
The way that you could trigger
this explicitly is by going,
"OK, so-and-so, talk to
'the name of the action'."
And so our canonical example
that we use is Personal Chef.
And so we're just
telling Google,
"I want to talk to this action."
You could also do
something where
you can bypass the
welcome and go straight
into the interactivity
that you want.
And so an example
is, "OK, Google--
ah, dang it, I said it.
So sorry.
So sorry-- ask Personal
Chef for a hot soup recipe."
So for the demo
that I filled out,
it would be something like,
"OK, sure, sure, sure, ask
My Bike Demo if mountain
bike tires are in stock."
That way, it bypasses the
welcome and all that jazz.
So our users are
getting really great
interactivity and
getting to what they want
to get done earlier and faster.
Another way to be able
to get your actions
triggered is
implicit triggering.
This has to do with
just asking Google,
"I want to do a
thing like this."
And this gets really similar to
when you just go to our website
and you type something in.
It gives you the best
results based off
of some really great algorithms.
And it will try to
surface the action
that Google thinks is best
for the user at that time.
So here are some examples
of implicit triggering.
We also have a directory.
So what I mentioned
earlier, you want
to put in all your
information, so we
do have a directory where I
know I love to go in there
and just check out what
other people are doing,
see what's going on.
So there's that.
And then this one I think
is the most impactful way
to communicate, is action links.
And so you could link
your Action from anywhere.
So let's say you have a social
media campaign that you're
building now and you want to
highlight that you spent all
this time building this Action.
You can actually
have a URL that could
post on Twitter or any
other social media platform
and send your users straight
to the Action itself.
So that's another
capability, too.
So here's a list
of all resources.
That way you have
everything you need.
Yeah, photos, please.
Like to put this at
the end, that way,
I believe, almost
everything I mentioned.
Here's a great
starting point for it.
All our resources on there.
Of course, we have our
own code labs and samples,
things exist out there.
Something I did really gloss
over completely was design.
When it comes to
building your Action,
we have a lot of great,
rich design documentation.
I know when I was building my
first Action, as a developer,
I saw design and I was like,
skip, skip, skip, skip.
That bit me in the tushie later.
That was not a good idea.
So please learn from me
and be better than me.
Really check out
the documentation
when it comes to design,
because there are many times
where you're building this
out and you could get lost
in the conversation, and where
you're at in the conversation
flow, or what type of
phrases people might use.
So I definitely highly
recommend go to the design docs,
write out the physical
conversations people might
be having, and using that
as your template versus just
trying to live code it.
We have great documentation
in regards to that.
We even have a code lab designed
for designing your Action as
well.
So that's that.
This is a way that
you could stay
connected, if you're interested,
on Actions on Google, being
part of the cool kids' club
and building your action.
So we're active on Google+, and
of course, our developers page,
and then on Twitter.
If you build
anything out, I would
love to know what you've done.
You could use the
hashtag #AoGDevs.
That's something that we are
usually checking out just
to see what people are building.
Then there's my contact
information down there.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]